Iraq's second-largest city Mosul was
still trying to rebuild after being
virtually torn apart during the rise of
ISIL and the battle to retake it it was
in June 2014 when ISIL seized the city
later that month Abu Bakr al-baghdadi
declared the creation of a so-called
Caliphate from there that happened in
the cities on Nouri mosque isil's
ideology fundamentally changed life in
Mosul with its members and forcing a
strict and repressive code of conduct on
people who live there the Iraqi
government announced an operation to
liberate Mosul in 2015 it was an
exhaustive battle lasting until mid 2017
when it turned into a street by street
fight for Mosul's old city by July 10th
victory was declared over ISIL Baghdadi
is from was from Iraq and he declared a
so-called Caliphate in Mosul and that is
where Natasha guy named joins us live so
Natasha as we said that body is gone but
the the aftermath of what he did is
still very real for people living in
Mosul I think it's safe to say that the
people not only here in Mosul but in all
of Iraq will be living with a
psychological trauma caused by ISIL for
a generation with regard to Mosul this
was the first city that ISIL took
control of this was the place where Abu
Bakr al Baghdadi came here to this grand
Elnora mosque it's a centuries-old
landmark in Iraq he said he was the
leader in 2014 of this group ironically
three years later ISIL bombed the mosque
as it retreated and government forces
retook control of the city since then
people continue to live in sheer misery
literally amid the rubble more than
300,000 residents of this city remain
displaced and I think it's safe to say
again that everyone carries the scars of
the ISIL atrocities
they're no longer in Amman how the
también we have been greatly harmed by
this terrorist organization damaged by
those gangsters who have no distinction
between the young and the old the
Muslims and non-muslims everyone has
been harmed in one way or another once
we heard the news we jumped for joy
simply because we have suffered for
years they have no mercy many families
lost their loved ones because of those
terrorists and may have some Abu Bakr al
Baghdadi
the residents venire are all delighted
by the death of this sinful person named
Abu Bakr al Baghdadi he was the cause of
destruction in an hour we're all
delighted to hear the news this vicious
man has smeared the religion he along
with other ISIL operatives have nothing
to do with Islam
he has caused harm to millions of people
namely the residents of Mosul no one was
spared the old the young men and women
we were very happy to hear the news of
his killing what benefit has he gained
thousands were killed I lost my wife
children including a newborn baby
because of him may Allah Almighty punish
him for all what he did part of isil's
modus operandi was attempting to erase
the cultural heritage here in Iraq by
destroying landmarks such as this in
fact this boss was so beloved rachelle
at one point it was on Iraqi currency
now UNESCO is working with the United
Arab Emirates to restore the
centuries-old mosque to its former glory
let's hope that does happen Natasha can
aim why for us in Mosul Natasha thank
you